vamos a analizar un poco lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado digamos que estoy
pidiendo prestados pesos
ok ese es entonces mi principal inicial
principal r es la tasa de interés que
también lo podemos ver como que la renta
que tenemos que pagar por año porque nos
presten ese dinero que lo podemos
escribir como 100 por r por ciento
y me los voy a pedir prestados por ti
años
ok veamos si podemos encontrar
ecuaciones que nos digan cuánto dinero
voy a deber después de años usando un
interés simple o interés compuesto bueno
vamos a hacer primero el interés simple
porque pues es simple bueno entonces a
ver después de cero años pues osea nada
más estoy regresando inmediatamente lo
que me prestaron y noten que para ningún
ningún interés por lo cual debo p
ok el después de un año en el tiempo uno
puede ver p más el interés no que es
como la renta durante un año porque me
presten ese dinero qué es rp en el vídeo
anterior que eran 100 pesos y r eran 10
por ciento por lo cual rp eran 10 pesos
y entonces tenía que pagar 10 pesos de
renta por año y bueno es igual a pp por
uno más r
después de dos años cuánto debemos pues
cada año tenemos que pagar otra vez el
interés no otra vez la renta del año que
es el reporte
y entonces cada año pagamos erp entonces
tenemos p más
rp qué es lo que debíamos en el año
pasado más otra vez la renta del año que
se ve que es para escribir como p por 1
más 12 r o sea si sacamos la p nos queda
nada más uno más dos cr uno más además
terreno en el año tres pues debemos lo
que vivíamos en el año anterior que esté
más rpp más rp y pagamos otro rp por la
renta de ese año
eso y eso es igual a p por 1 3er
entonces saber después de años
cuánto debemos pues debemos nuestro
principal original por uno más
r
lo podemos distribuir porque cada año
pagamos pr iba a verte años bien y
supongamos que yo quiero pedir prestado
50 pesos a lo largo de 20 años no deben
de recordar así nada más las fórmulas
hay que saber de qué se nos están
hablando bien entonces son 50 pesos con
un interés del 15 por ciento simple
durante 20 años
al final de los 20 años yo debería 50
pesos por uno más
el tiempo que son 20 por la tasa de
interés que es punto 15
y eso es igual a 50 pesos por 1
3 que es 20.15 lo cual es igual a 50 por
4 que es igual a 200 pesos para pedir
prestado 50 pesos a lo largo de 20 años
200 pesos bueno esto fue interés simple
y esta es la fórmula veamos si podemos
hacer lo mismo con el interés compuesto
y para eso primero queremos borrar todo
esto
no es como yo lo quería borrar
muy bien ahí está
bien entonces con el interés compuesto
en el año 1 cómo vives en el vídeo
pasado es exactamente lo mismo que en el
interés simple que hay de bp más el
interés o sea la tasa por el principal y
eso es igual
ap por 10 muy bien
en el año 2 es donde el interés simple
el interés compuesto toman formas
distintas
en el interés compuesto esto se
convierte en el nuevo principal entonces
si este es el nuevo principal tenemos
que pagar uno va a ser por esto nuestro
principal al final de la p después de un
año pagamos p por uno más r
aquí está el pp por 10 que es uno más la
taza y para ir al año 2 necesitamos
pagar lo que debemos al final del año 1
que esté por uno más cr y luego lo
tenemos que multiplicar por nuestra tasa
baja que es uno más ser multiplicarlo
por uno más r
y eso es igual a p por uno más r al
cuadrado y bueno en el interés simple
cada año le sumamos un p por r
cada año le sumamos el principal por la
tasa por r en este caso sería 50 por
punto 15 que son las cuentas son 7.5
pesos cada año
en el interés compuesto cada año estamos
multiplicando al principal por 1 más la
tasa
bien entonces si vamos al año 3 vamos a
multiplicar esto por 1 más r entonces
tenemos t por uno más r al cubo y en el
año te vamos a tener que pagar te por
uno más r a la décima potencia veamos en
este ejemplo donde vivimos con el
interés simple y que deberíamos 200
pesos cuánto deberíamos con el interés
compuesto el principal son 50 pesos
por uno más la tasa que es punto 15 y lo
estamos viendo lo estamos rentando por
20 años y eso es igual a 50 x 1.15 a la
20 la potencia
bueno aquí no se ve muy bien pero se
entienden veamos qué puedo hacer con un
20 la potencia a ver usando cualquier
calculadora nosotros vamos a usar excel
a ver dónde está el comando aunque o
mejor voy a usar el mouse
a ver borremos todo
ok entonces a ver aquí le ponemos 1.15 a
la veinteava potencia
y nos queda 16.37 que entonces todo esto
es igual a 50 por el paréntesis a la 20
que es 16.37 como acabamos de ver en la
calculadora
ok y lo queremos multiplicar por 50
818 pesos
qué 818 pesos
se nota la diferencia o sea si alguien
te está rentando su dinero y te lo va a
rentar durante mucho tiempo es muy
importante saber o sea aclarar si te van
a cargar el 15% de interés sobre un
interés simple a un interés compuesto
porque hay mucha diferencia o sea con el
interés compuesto estamos pagando más de
600 pesos más
desafortunadamente generalmente en el
mundo real se utiliza el interés
compuesto y no se compone cada año ni
cada seis meses ni cada cinco días se
compone de una forma continua entonces
bueno tienen que ver los siguientes
vídeos para entender de qué estoy
hablando y también van a aprender mucho
acerca de la magia del número y bueno
los veo en el siguiente vídeo